this is a really common misunderstanding
if you look at how much uv is coming in
and hitting your skin you're actually
getting a bit more than one and a half
times as much uv with spf 30 compared to
spf 50. and these percentages are just
theoretical it's what you get if you
apply exactly two milligrams per square
centimeter completely perfectly evenly
which no one does most people apply a
quarter to a half of what you're meant
to apply which means you're actually
getting four to eight percent uv with
spf 50 and seven to 14 uv with spf 30
and that's on average there'll be spots
where you have a lot less sunscreen but
if you apply the same amount of spf 30
and spf 50 you're always getting a bit
more than one and a half times uv with
spf 30. studies that actually looked at
people playing sunscreen have found that
people burn significantly more with spf
50 compared to spf 100. so the moral of
the story is go with the highest sps
sunscreen that you can apply a lot of
regularly something with the texture
that you like that fits your budget
because if you don't actually wear the
sunscreen it won't work